hi meredith i've been cyber stalking you
all weekend
oh my gosh i can't believe that i'm so
excited to meet you drew
thank you for having me i'm so excited
to meet you too
and it's really interesting to meet the
woman behind the woman
and did you know that you would end up
in the fashion industry
or was it like a pivot i mean
how did you get into this um i
yeah i definitely did not think
that i was going to be working in
fashion
it was never part of my world growing up
um except in my fantasy world in my head
but i actually grew up dancing and i
went on to study psychology
i wanted to be a dancer for a time i
wasn't good enough
oh well that's okay and a random
series of life events led me to working
with michelle obama which is
crazy not something i would have ever
imagined expected
even dreamt about like it wasn't it
wasn't in my wildest dreams
well in honor of beauty week the two of
us have teamed up
um to guide one of our vff's who was
wanting some help in the beauty and
fashion department
um so let's take a look at what we did
with amy
hi everyone my name is amy i live in
riverside california with my husband and
two children
i would really love some help in the
beauty and fashion department
i've been stuck in a makeup rut for
almost 20 years now
i would love some advice on better
colors to go with my
skin tones and my eyes and hair color
as far as fashion is concerned i tend to
be quite casual
so i would love an upgrade a fancier
outfit that i could wear
on a special date night i'm only five
feet tall
so i'm also looking for something that
would be flattering on my shorter
stature
drew meredith can you please help me out
hi amy i'm so excited to meet you
so if you're ready to open your box i am
going to take you through everything
that i
personally hand picked for you this is
the
it foundation it cosmetics their famous
cc cream with
50 spf for you perfect
it looks really pretty now i noticed
that you said you were open to a
powdered blush
so i got you this this is the company i
have it's flower beauty it's
rosy it's perfect for your skin tone and
it's giving the right amount of light
reflection
this is a new pencil for sf flower
so i got you the smoky topaz i also
brought you
our amethyst which one are you more
drawn to
pun intended can we go for the amethyst
yes perfect my favorite trick is you
open up the inside of the upper water
line
and you go all the way over and it
massively opens up your eyes
okay oh that looks good
and then i went with a brown
mascara for you i'd like you to give
yourself like
two or three coats of this okay one coat
of mascara is
never enough with your blue
eye color i thought these beautiful
taupe
and bronzy and brown tones were really
good
now grab your charlotte tilbury pillow
talk
lipstick it's a beautiful color
oh i'm so glad you're pleased i love a
nice
neutral rosy tone oh my gosh amy i think
you look so pretty
hi amy it's great to meet you so i
sent over some options for you to try on
so why don't we start and open that
first box
oh yay amy what do you think i
love it i love the style this looks
amazing on you
it was so important to pick things that
have the right proportion for your
body another thing i love about this
dress is that it's
secondhand and it's a great way to shop
if you want to reduce your impact on the
environment and also if you want to
save some money let's open up that
second box
oh my gosh you look so
good this is amazing it just seems
fun kind of flirty and i love the style
i love this print with your hair
and your skin okay amy third and final
box
let's do it oh my gosh you're so cute
this is bold it's new i really like it
very 60s inspired we've got the a-line
shape
the little cap sleeve really interesting
detail at the neckline that we're gonna
see
i know what my favorite is i know what i
think you're gonna choose
so i can't wait to see all right and amy
is here to show us her
final look first the makeup
amy you look so beautiful
how are you feeling about the new
application
i absolutely love it especially the
brown tones
i feel like it really does match my hair
my skin tone so much better than
traditionally what i was wearing
and the lipstick perfect for daytime or
night i absolutely love it thank you
so much all right meredith over to you
great yes
[Applause]
by the way your shape and skin
look just gorgeous yes
um i love the proportion of this we've
got
this part of the body showing which is
elongating for her amy is truly
a petite size and so showing
this skin in the way that we did
elongates
the leg as well you look stunning
gorgeous thank you i absolutely love it
i especially i love the fluttery sleeves
the print i love blues so
this is just perfect what's your
mentality going into date night now
i am so ready
well um amy i mean listen we've all like
been with you and now i've been
investing can you please tell us how the
date night went i really like to follow
up
absolutely love to do that okay cool
and meredith what an honor and a
pleasure to work with you
i would love to do this again yes
amy and meredith thank you so much
you